we're supposed to be the best goddamn
country in the world is the best we can
do my god whoa Alaska leads the nation
in sexual violence it is the National
epicenter he kidnapped her he tricked
her and he sexually assaulted her silent
anymore he got a get-out-of-jail-free
pass for what he did to this young lady
activists in Alaska are trying to bring
down a judge who gave no jail time to a
man who assaulted a young Native woman
if they're successful the judge could be
voted out during midterm elections we
are gonna hold all of them accountable
because that's how we end rape culture
in Alaska is we are going to call out
everybody who had a part in this and
Judge Michael Cory is one of them
back in August 2017 an air traffic
controller named justin schneider was on
his way to work in the middle of the day
and stopped by a gas station in the
middle of anchorage alaska and he
pretended to know this woman who was
hanging out at the gas station we don't
know this woman might name but we know
that she was a 25 year old alaska native
woman he pretended to know her and
offered to give her a ride to her
boyfriend's home on the other side of
town and she accepted and got in the car
I'm instead he took her somewhere else
and he made her get out of the car he
strangled her with both hands telling
her that he was going to kill her she
then passed out and he ejaculated all
over her face and hair and then when she
woke up he was standing over her with
his pants unzipped she immediately
called 9-1-1 she reported his license
plate she picked him out of a lineup she
did everything she was supposed to do at
some point during this process the
prosecution dropped three of the felony
assault charges and the sexual charges
he walked free out of the court with no
jail time did not have to register as a
sex offender
what schneider did is not considered a
sex crime under Alaska law but there is
a way his plea deal could have been
denied Judge Corey was at the end of
this he could have said you know this is
not what we stand for he could have said
something the judge in question Michael
Corey technically could have rejected
the plea deal and called for a harsher
sentence for Schneider but he didn't and
many activists say this happens all too
often I am a white woman and I think
that if I had been the victim in this
case
Justin Schneider would have walked away
with several years of jail time I do not
think that the state of Alaska takes
sexual assault seriously I think our
statistics prove it
what we have is an epidemic of sexual
assault and violence against women
Alaska sexual assault rate is three
times higher than the national average
59 percent of women here say they're
victims of sexual or domestic violence
so I'm a social worker I work with
children and families and I see lots and
lots of domestic violence and sexual
assault
I myself am a survivor of sexual assault
so I think I understand it and I I think
I know a little bit of what that victim
may have felt
we know that half of the sexual assaults
in Alaska are against Native women even
though they only make up 20% of the
population your voice was not silenced
like the many Alaska Native women in our
community have been silenced what
happened to my great-great-grandmother
what happened to many women in my family
is not gonna happen to my daughter you
know this is really important to the
Alaska Natives because for a long time
they have been silenced not only for
Alaska Natives but for indigenous people
all across this continent I think we
have to look at the history of where
we're at in this country and realize
that our institutions were created by
white womanizing indigenous hating slave
owning white men and like that is still
affecting us today and like I may not be
indigenous and I may not be a woman but
coming from being african-american being
a vet and have an indigenous son that
when I need help when my community comes
under attack this community is gonna
extend its hand out to us too and that's
the only way we're going to get through
what we're going through this isn't the
first time a judge has come under
question for lenient sentencing
California judge Aaron Persky was
recalled after he sentenced Brock Turner
to only six months in jail after Turner
sexually assaulted an unconscious woman
enough is enough we need to send a
message to the bench and to the criminal
division that we are paying attention as
Alaskans we are informed citizens and we
are going to use the judicial process to
make ourselves heard in November
activists say the judge campaign is just
the first stop they're on a mission to
reform Alaskan law to better protect
women and we want to send a message to
the judges to the Department of Law into
the legislature that we're not going to
tolerate that anymore
it does create this deep anger
judge Cory really allowed a lot of open
wounds to come out I see so much hope
for change right now right now the time
where women are stepping up and speaking
truth and I feel like that's a really
monumental thing everyone right now are
the ones that are going to change these
systems we're not gonna let our
indigenous women go missing we're not
going to let them be murdered assaulted
and we're certainly not going to let
their perpetrators off with a pass
[Music]